[Musique]
de 10 mètres de haut se châtaigniers du
xviiie siècle est considéré comme arbre
remarquable
il fait partie de ces végétaux qui ont
permis au parc de la brunette riz
d'orgeval d'obtenir le label ensemble à
rebours est remarquable nous avons
sélectionné des arbres qui ont eu eux
pluri centenaire donc notamment il y en
a un qui est emblématique est derrière
moi un pain noir qui lui est bon datent
du 19e et qui a été justement qui nous a
fait gagner une partie de ces de ce
label il y a aussi des châtaigniers un
peu plus loin petit date eux qui rompt
300 ans l'association les amis du
domaine de la brune et riz a voulu
préserver ce parc de 5 ha paysager en
obtenant le label c'est un engagement à
entretenir ce patrimoine arboré un lieu
qui va devenir à la fois un
environnement naturel est un endroit de
convivialité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va faire des aménagements importants
notamment artistiques
avec ce qu'on appelle une arboré al sur
la sur l'esplanade qui servira de halle
également il y aura une toile qui sera
tendu il y aura des animations il va y
avoir des concerts il va y avoir les
animations associatives donc c'est un
parent qui va vivre de la même manière
cette association nous a incités à voter
en conseil municipal également la
déclaration des droits de l'arbre qui
montre bien à quel point ce sujet
intéresse notre notre commune aux
documents qui marque une volonté de
mettre l'arbre au centre des
préoccupations de la ville d'orgeval
elle est affichée à deux entrées du parc
de la paix m